From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life-- I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》——我是艾拉·格拉斯。
[MUSIC - "MYSTERY OF THE DUNBAR'S CHILD" BY RICHARD "RABBIT" BROWN]
[音乐 - 理查德·“兔子”·布朗演唱的《邓巴孩子的谜团》]
It used to be if something was big news, it got turned into a song. This one's about a famous kidnapping that happened in 1912, the kidnapping of Bobby Dunbar, a four-year-old boy. For two years, the details of his disappearance, and the search for him, and how he was found, and the trial of his kidnapper was all front page news, reported breathlessly all across the country.
过去，如果有重大新闻，它往往会被编成歌曲。这首歌讲的是1912年发生的一起著名绑架案，受害者是四岁的男孩鲍比·邓巴。在接下来的两年里，他失踪的细节、搜救过程、他被找到的方式，以及对他绑架者的审判，全部成为了头版新闻，在全国范围内被狂热地报道。
But some of the biggest mysteries of the case were never solved, until long after nearly everybody involved was dead, almost a century after it happened, the mysteries finally got solved when one of Bobby Dunbar's descendants started poking around the old stories, looking for answers she wasn't really expecting to find.
但该案中一些最大的谜团直到几乎所有相关人员去世后才被解开。在事件发生近一个世纪后，当鲍比·邓巴的一位后代开始挖掘这些旧事时，谜团终于被解开了，她寻找的是自己并没预料到会发现的答案。
Today, we devote our entire show to the legend of Bobby Dunbar and to what his granddaughter discovered-- the messy, real story of what actually happened, which, as you'll hear, turns out to be a lot more interesting than the legend. Tal McThenia is our reporter.
今天，我们将整期节目献给鲍比·邓巴的传奇故事，以及他孙女的发现——关于实际发生之事的混乱而真实的叙述，正如你所听到的，这比传说要有趣得多。塔尔·麦克塞尼亚是我们的记者。
Everybody in the family knew it-- the legend of Bobby Dunbar, the lost boy who was found.
家里每个人都知道这个传奇——鲍比·邓巴，那个失而复得的男孩的传说。
Well, the legend was that, back in the early 1900s, my grandfather became missing.
嗯，传说是这样的：20世纪初，我的祖父失踪了。
My grandfather had gone on a camping trip with his parents. It was on a lake.
我祖父当时和父母去露营。地点在一个湖边。
Swayze Lake. It's actually a swamp in Louisiana. And he disappeared.
斯韦兹湖。那实际上是路易斯安那州的一片沼泽。然后他失踪了。
Bobby was just four years old at the time, and Swayze Lake was teeming with alligators, surrounded by dark, thick woods. There was a massive search that started in the swamp and spread across the country, but nothing for eight months, until--
鲍比当时只有四岁，斯韦兹湖里挤满了短吻鳄，周围是阴暗茂密的树林。一场大规模的搜寻从沼泽开始，蔓延到全国，但八个月内一无所获，直到——
They found him in Mississippi in the hands of a Mr. Walters.
他们在密西西比州找到了他，当时他在一位沃尔特斯先生手中。
The peddler in Columbia, Mississippi.
就是密西西比州哥伦比亚市的那个小贩。
They brought him home. Rode in on a fire truck.
他们把他带回了家。坐着消防车回来的。
There was a tremendous parade, with a fire truck. And the whole town came out. And there was a band, and everybody celebrated. And he was found.
当时举行了盛大的游行，有消防车。全镇的人都出来了。有乐队，每个人都在庆祝。他被找到了。
But Bobby Dunbar wasn't out of danger yet. Someone else tried to claim him, another mother. She'd lost her child, too, and said that the boy they found in Mississippi was hers. There was a big trial that proved her wrong, and Bobby stayed with his parents, Percy and Lessie Dunbar, in Opelousas, where he lived for the rest of his life.
但鲍比·邓巴还没脱离危险。另一个人试图认领他，另一位母亲。她也丢了孩子，并说在密西西比找到的那个男孩是她的。经过一场大审判证明她错了，鲍比和他的父母珀西及莱西·邓巴留在了奥佩卢萨斯，他在那里度过了余生。
It was just a story, a tale you would tell your grandchildren.
这只是一个故事，一个你会讲给孙辈听的传说。
Which she would know. She was one of them. Margaret Dunbar Cutright, out of everyone in the family, was the most captivated by the legend of her grandfather's kidnapping. As a girl, she would beg her grandmother to tell the story over and over. When she had children of her own, Margaret told them the legend, too.
她很清楚这一点。她是他的孙女之一。在家族所有人中，玛格丽特·邓巴·卡特赖特对她祖父被绑架的传奇最为着迷。小时候，她会缠着祖母一遍又一遍地讲这个故事。当她有了自己的孩子后，玛格丽特也把这个传奇告诉了他们。
Then, in 1999, her younger brother, Robbie, died in a plane crash. A month later, she was sitting in the den with her father, and he gave her a scrapbook that had been her great grandmother's, overstuffed with photographs and letters and newspaper clippings from the early 1900s, all about her grandfather's kidnapping.
1999年，她年轻的弟弟罗比死于空难。一个月后，她和父亲坐在书房里，父亲给了她一本曾祖母留下的剪贴簿，里面塞满了20世纪初的照片、信件和剪报，全都是关于她祖父被绑架的内容。
It was about 400 articles, not in chronological order. Dad said, this would be a great project for you, Margaret. He had no idea what would come of that.
大约有400篇文章，没有按时间顺序排列。爸爸说，玛格丽特，这会是一个很棒的项目。他根本不知道这会引出什么。
Without realizing it, Bob had set his daughter on a path that would nearly tear their family apart. But in the beginning, all Margaret knew was that the scrapbook felt like the thing she'd been waiting for. In 1999, her kids were growing up and in the house less and less. Her husband, Wayne, was working in a different state and only home on weekends. And Margaret was in mourning for her brother. She had long, empty days, and the scrapbook could fill them.
在毫无察觉的情况下，鲍勃让他女儿踏上了一条几乎会让家庭破裂的道路。但起初，玛格丽特只觉得这本剪贴簿就像她一直在等待的东西。1999年，她的孩子们长大了，回家的次数越来越少。她的丈夫韦恩在另一个州工作，只有周末才回来。玛格丽特正沉浸在失去弟弟的悲痛中。她有漫长而空虚的日子，而这本剪贴簿可以填满它们。
But the more she dug in, the more she began to realize this was not the breezy adventure tale she'd grown up imagining. Even the simplest moments in the story, like when her great grandparents are finally united with their son after an eight-month-long national search. Reporters from several papers were following the couple, Lessie and Percy Dunbar, on the train to Mississippi. Throngs of people were surrounding the house where the boy was being kept. Lessie and Percy went inside, but reports diverge on what happened next.
但她挖掘得越深，就越开始意识到这不是她从小想象的那种轻松的冒险故事。即使是故事里最简单的瞬间，比如她的曾祖父母在经历八个月的全国大搜寻后终于与儿子团聚时。几家报社的记者跟踪这对夫妇，莱西和珀西·邓巴，坐火车前往密西西比。成群结队的人围在男孩被安置的房子周围。莱西和珀西进去了，但报道对接下来发生的事情各执一词。
This article says that the mother faints. The headline reads, "Mother Faints, Sight of Kidnapped Child. When the mother reached the house where the boy was being kept, he was asleep. Mrs. Dunbar made a careful examination of the lad without awakening him and was standing over the bed a few hours later, when the child opened his eyes. The boy recognized his mother instantly. 'Mother,' he cried as he reached up and stretched out his arms to her. The mother convulsively embraced the boy and then fainted."
这篇文章说母亲晕倒了。标题写道：“母亲看到被绑架的孩子时晕倒了。当母亲到达安置男孩的房子时，他正在睡觉。邓巴夫人在没有吵醒他的情况下仔细检查了男孩，几小时后，当孩子睁开眼睛时，她正站在床边。男孩立即认出了他的母亲。‘妈妈，’他喊道，伸手向她伸出双臂。母亲激动地拥抱了男孩，然后晕倒了。”
And the second article, the headline was, "Mrs. Dunbar Not Positive Lad is Her Missing Boy. When they reached the home, the child was asleep at the time. When awakened, it began to cry. Mrs. Dunbar looked in the dim light of a smoky oil lamp and then fell back with a gasp. 'I do not know. I am not quite sure,' faltered Mrs. Dunbar."
第二篇文章的标题是：“邓巴夫人不能肯定男孩是她失踪的儿子。当他们到达家中时，孩子正在睡觉。被吵醒后，他开始哭。邓巴夫人在昏暗的油灯光线下看了看，然后倒吸一口凉气向后退去。‘我不知道。我不确定，’邓巴夫人支吾着。”
In fact, Percy and Lessie both told the papers that the boy didn't look like their son. His eyes were too small. But then the next day, they came back and Lessie gave the boy a bath and identified the moles and scars on his skin and declared he was hers. And according to some newspapers, Bobby didn't recognize his father or mother, either, or his brother Alonzo.
事实上，珀西和莱西都告诉报社，这个男孩看起来不像他们的儿子。他的眼睛太小了。但第二天，他们又回来，莱西给男孩洗了个澡，识别了他皮肤上的痣和伤疤，并断定他就是她的孩子。根据一些报纸的说法，鲍比也没有认出他的父亲、母亲或他的兄弟阿隆佐。
One paper said, quote, "Bobby, at first meeting, turns upon Alonzo with a scowl of anger. There appeared no recognition of his little brother." And then another paper said, quote, "The instant they met, Robert said, 'there's my bubba, Alonzo,' and reached over and kissed him."
一份报纸说，引文：“鲍比在第一次见面时，皱着眉头转向阿隆佐。他似乎认不出他的小兄弟。”而另一份报纸说，引文：“他们见面的那一刻，罗伯特说，‘那是我的哥哥阿隆佐’，然后走过去吻了他。”
It was a frequent occurrence in the newspapers to contradict one another. It's very difficult to know for certain what really happened.
报纸之间相互矛盾的情况很常见。很难确定到底发生了什么。
So to sort out what happened, to try to get to the truth of the story, Margaret went on an obsessive quest to small-town libraries and archives and courthouses all over the South. For her birthday, her husband gave her a card for the Library of Congress, and she spent weeks in the reading rooms there.
为了理清真相，为了寻找故事的真面目，玛格丽特开始了痴迷的探寻，跑遍了南方各地的小镇图书馆、档案馆和法院。她生日时，丈夫送给她一张国会图书馆的阅览证，她在那里度过了几周。
And as she dug into the historical record, certain figures from the family legend started to seem like real people for the first time. Take the mother who came forward and claimed that Bobby Dunbar was actually her child. Margaret had never given her much thought. She'd just been the woman trying to steal her grandfather. But in the newspapers, this woman has a name-- Julia Anderson. She's a single mom working in North Carolina as a field hand and a caretaker for the parents of William C. Walters, the kidnapper.
随着她深入挖掘历史记录，家族传说中的某些人物第一次看起来像是真实的人。以那位站出来声称鲍比·邓巴实际上是她孩子的母亲为例。玛格丽特以前从没太在意她。她只是那个试图偷走她祖父的女人。但在报纸上，这个女人有一个名字——朱莉娅·安德森。她是一位单身母亲，在北卡罗来纳州做田间劳工，并照顾绑架者威廉·C·沃尔特斯的父母。
Walters claimed that Julia gave him the boy willingly, that his name wasn't Bobby Dunbar, but Bruce Anderson, and that they'd been traveling together for over a year. When Julia first shows up in the papers, she confirms his story, although she contests some of his details.
沃尔特斯声称朱莉娅是自愿把孩子交给他的，这孩子不叫鲍比·邓巴，而是布鲁斯·安德森，他们已经在一起旅行了一年多。当朱莉娅第一次出现在报纸上时，她证实了他的说法，尽管她对其中的一些细节提出了异议。
The first article that even brought her into light, in a way-- there was an affidavit printed. "William C. Walters left Barnesville, North Carolina, with my son, Charles Bruce, in February of 1912, saying that he only wanted to take the child with him for a few days on a visit to the home of his sister. I have not seen the child from that day to this. I did not give him the child, I merely consented for him to take my son for a few days.
第一篇让她出现在公众视野的文章，印了一份宣誓书。“威廉·C·沃尔特斯于1912年2月带着我的儿子查尔斯·布鲁斯离开了北卡罗来纳州的巴恩斯维尔，说他只是想带孩子去他姐姐家住几天。从那天起我就没见过孩子。我没有把孩子交给他，我只是同意让他带我儿子去几天。
Walters had been at the home of his father, Mr. JP Walters, near Barnesville since November of 1911. And while he was there, he and the child were together a great deal and seemed very fond of each other. The boy would go anywhere with Walters. I would know my son if I were to see him, and I am sure he would know me. I have no picture of the child, but have a lock of his hair."
自1911年11月以来，沃尔特斯一直住在位于巴恩斯维尔附近的父亲JP·沃尔特斯先生的家中。当他住在那里时，他和孩子待在一起的时间很多，似乎非常喜欢对方。男孩会和沃尔特斯去任何地方。如果我看到儿子，我一定能认出他，我也相信他能认出我。我没有孩子的照片，但有一撮他的头发。”
What was your reaction to that?
你对此有什么反应？
Her statement struck me as a very truthful statement. This woman was telling truth. She did have a son. And my heart hurts for Julia at this point, believing that this boy is her son. You know, it's really awkward because Lessie and Julia are in the same position. They're both missing children.
她的陈述给我的感觉是非常真实的陈述。这个女人在说真话。她的确有个儿子。此时此刻，想到这个女人相信这男孩是她的儿子，我的心感到疼痛。你知道，这真的很尴尬，因为莱西和朱莉娅处在同样的位置。她们都丢了孩子。
From May of 1913 on, Julia was all over the headlines. A New Orleans paper paid for her trip to Opelousas to see if she really could identify the boy as hers. The story, as it was played out in the front pages, was this. Julia arrived, weary from an overnight train ride, and was taken into an Opelousas home. Five boys around Bruce's age, including the child the Dunbars had claimed as Bobby, were brought in at different times, and Julia had to choose. When Bobby came in, he was in tears, and so was Julia. He showed no signs of recognition, even when she offered him an orange. But Julia asked the lawyers in the room if this was the child who was recovered. They refused to answer.
从1913年5月开始，朱莉娅登上了所有头条。一家新奥尔良报纸资助她去奥佩卢萨斯，看看她是否真的能认出那个男孩。故事在头版上的发展是这样的：朱莉娅带着彻夜乘火车的疲惫到达，被带到奥佩卢萨斯的一户人家。五个和布鲁斯年龄相仿的男孩，包括邓巴一家声称是鲍比的那个孩子，被分批带进来，朱莉娅必须从中指认。当鲍比进来时，他泪流满面，朱莉娅也是。他没有表现出认出的迹象，即使当她递给他一个橙子时。但朱莉娅问在场的律师这是否是找回的那个孩子。他们拒绝回答。
Finally, she said she just didn't know, and the test was declared a failure. Julia begged for a second chance. And the next day, she was allowed to see the boy again and undress him. This time, she felt more certain that it was her son. But her failure the night before was already national news. Julia had no lawyer and no money and very few allies in Opelousas, so she left town and began the long trip back to North Carolina. And from that point on, the boy was Bobby Dunbar.
最后，她说她实在不知道，测试被宣布失败。朱莉娅请求再给一次机会。第二天，她被允许再次见到男孩并为他脱去衣服。这一次，她更确信那是她的儿子。但她前一天晚上的失败已经成为全国新闻。朱莉娅没有律师，没有钱，在奥佩卢萨斯几乎没有盟友，所以她离开了小镇，开始了回北卡罗来纳的长途跋涉。从那时起，这个男孩就成了鲍比·邓巴。
The more Margaret learned about Julia Anderson's life, the more tragic the story seemed. Julia had three children by two different men, neither her husband. And she'd lost all her children in just a single year-- a daughter she gave up for adoption, a baby whose sudden death she was wrongfully blamed for, and now Bruce. But the newspapers weren't very sympathetic. They implied she was a prostitute, called her illiterate and naive. Take this article in the New Orleans Item titled, "Julia Has Forgotten."
玛格丽特对朱莉娅·安德森的生活了解得越多，这个故事似乎就越悲惨。朱莉娅先后与两个男人育有三个孩子，都不是她的丈夫。她一年之内失去了所有的孩子——一个送给别人领养的女儿，一个因突然死亡而背上冤屈的婴儿，现在又是布鲁斯。但报纸并不怎么同情她。他们暗示她是妓女，称她目不识丁、天真无知。看看《新奥尔良物品》中这篇题为《朱莉娅已经忘记了》的文章。
"Julia Has Forgotten," by Jerome G. Beatty. "Her long journey had been in vain. She had not seen her son since February of 1912, and she had forgotten him. Animals don't forget, but this big, coarse countrywoman, several times a mother, she forgot. She cared little for her young. Children were only regrettable incidents in her life."
《朱莉娅已经忘记了》，杰罗姆·G·比蒂著。“她的长途跋涉是徒劳的。自1912年2月以来，她就没见过儿子，她已经忘了他。动物不会忘记，但这个粗鲁的乡下女人，当了几次母亲的她，却忘了。她不在乎自己的孩子。孩子只是她生命中令人遗憾的插曲。”
Now, see? I hate this article.
看，我讨厌这篇文章。
"She hopes her son isn't dead, just as she hopes that the cotton crop will be good this year. Of true mother love, she has none."
“她希望儿子没死，就像她希望今年的棉花丰收一样。对于真正的母爱，她一点也没有。”
See? How judgmental.
看到了吗？多么带有偏见。
Then one day, Margaret found a Julia Anderson listed on an online genealogy site with this biographical note. Quote, "Julia had a son from her first marriage, named Bruce, who was kidnapped from North Carolina when he was six years old and taken to Louisiana. She tried to get him back, but the people that kidnapped him won him in court and changed his name to Bobby Dunbar."
有一天，玛格丽特在一个在线家谱网站上发现了一个名叫朱莉娅·安德森的人，上面有这样一段生平说明。引文：“朱莉娅与第一次婚姻中生有一个叫布鲁斯的儿子，他在六岁时从北卡罗来纳州被绑架到路易斯安那州。她试图要回他，但绑架他的人在法庭上胜诉，并将他的名字改为鲍比·邓巴。”
Well, that was not what my grandmother told me. That was not right.
嗯，那不是我祖母告诉我的。那是不对的。
It was like an upside down world opened up to Margaret, with a family who believed exactly the opposite of what her family believed. And in 2000, Margaret did what nobody else in her family, to her knowledge, had ever done before. She went to meet and visit with the descendants of Julia Anderson, her two living children, Hollis Rawls and Jewel Tarver, and Jewel's daughter, Linda.
这就像一个颠倒的世界在玛格丽特面前打开，另一家人相信的完全与她家人相信的相反。2000年，玛格丽特做了据她所知家族中从没人做过的事。她去拜访了朱莉娅·安德森的后代，她两个尚在世的孩子霍利斯·罗尔斯和朱厄尔·塔弗，以及朱厄尔的女儿琳达。
My name is Linda Tarver, and I'm the daughter of Jewel Rawls Tarver, who is the daughter of Julia Anderson. And Julia Anderson would be my grandmother.
我的名字是琳达·塔弗，我是朱厄尔·罗尔斯·塔弗的女儿，她又是朱莉娅·安德森的女儿。朱莉娅·安德森就是我的祖母。
All of us cousins grew up-- we knew that we had an uncle that had been taken by the Dunbar family in Opelousas, Louisiana. We always said "kidnapped." We said they kidnapped him.
我们所有堂表亲从小就知道，我们有一个叔叔被路易斯安那州奥佩卢萨斯的邓巴一家带走了。我们一直说是“绑架”。我们说他们绑架了他。
From the Andersons, Margaret learned what happened to Julia after the controversy over Bobby Dunbar. Julia moved to Poplarville, Mississippi, 200 miles east of Opelousas, got married, and had seven children. Jewel and Hollis are the youngest, now in their 80s.
从安德森一家那里，玛格丽特了解到了鲍比·邓巴风波后朱莉娅的遭遇。朱莉娅搬到了距离奥佩卢萨斯以东200英里的密西西比州波普拉维尔，结了婚，生了七个孩子。朱厄尔和霍利斯是最小的，现在已经80多岁了。
Talking to Jewel and Hollis and Linda, a very different picture of Julia emerges than the one in the newspapers of a barely literate woman of loose morals. Here's Linda.
与朱厄尔、霍利斯和琳达交谈，一个与报纸上描绘的那个几乎目不识丁、道德败坏的女人截然不同的朱莉娅形象浮现出来。这是琳达的话。
Grandmother loved to read, and she used to read Zane Grey books. And then she would sit them around at night and she would tell them the stories that she had read that day. But then, when she became a Christian, she decided reading Zane Grey was the wrong thing to, so they never got anymore Zane Grey stories, but they had to listen to the Bible then.
祖母很喜欢读书，她过去常读赞恩·格雷的书。然后她会在晚上把他们聚在一起，讲述她那天读到的故事。但后来，当她成为基督徒后，她决定读赞恩·格雷是不对的，所以他们再也没听过赞恩·格雷的故事，但那时他们必须听圣经。
We went to church, I'm telling you.
我告诉你，我们去教堂。
And you behaved, too, in church.
而且你在教堂里也表现得很好。
This is Jewel and Hollis, Julia's children.
这就是朱莉娅的孩子朱厄尔和霍利斯。
And we'd walk through these woods, across an old hickory log, across a creek, and go to church. And it'd be dinnertime before we'd leave, and we'd starve to death before we got home.
我们会穿过这些树林，跨过一根古老的山核桃原木，穿过一条小溪，去教堂。我们得等到晚饭时间才走，回家前我们都饿坏了。
Hollis and Jewel revere their mother. Julia didn't just go to church, they say, she founded the church. She was a nurse and a midwife for the entire community. During the Depression, she sewed all her children's clothes out of fertilizer bags. And they were always well fed. There was only one thing missing.
霍利斯和朱厄尔敬仰他们的母亲。他们说，朱莉娅不仅仅是去教堂，她还创办了教堂。她是整个社区的护士和助产士。大萧条时期，她用化肥袋缝制了所有孩子的衣服。他们总是吃得很好。只有一个遗憾。
She always talked about Bruce, but she called him Bobby. She was always looking for him.
她总是谈论布鲁斯，但她叫他鲍比。她一直在找他。
She never forgot it-- never, ever forgot the boy. And she'd always, once in a while, bring it up, and what the boy looked like. And she'd take a while to tell it, you know, about he did so and so and this, that, and the other, you know? And if it'd been possible for her to have got the child legally back or anything, she would have done it, if possible. She would have. She loved the child. She loved Bruce. She sure did.
她从未忘记，从来没有，从来没有忘记那个男孩。偶尔她还会提起来，讲他长什么样。她会花点时间讲出来，关于他做过这样那样的事，你知道吗？如果当时她有可能在法律上把孩子要回来，她会做的，如果可能的话。她会的。她爱那个孩子。她爱布鲁斯。她确实爱他。
So growing up, you knew that Bruce was out there.
所以你从小就知道布鲁斯在外面。
We knew.
我们知道。
We knew we had a brother.
我们知道我们有一个兄弟。
We knew it.
我们知道。
We knew that.
We kept thinking, well, one day, we'll get to go to this town, and we'll find him. But we never did go.
我们一直想，好吧，总有一天，我们会去那个小镇，找到他。但我们从未去过。
Even though Opelousas is just 200 miles from Poplarville, they didn't have a lot of money back then, and that kind of travel was expensive. They told me that when Julia went back up to North Carolina for her mother's funeral, they had to sell the family mule to pay for the trip. But it wasn't just the cost, Hollis says.
尽管奥佩卢萨斯距离波普拉维尔只有200英里，但他们当时钱不多，那种旅行很贵。他们告诉我，当朱莉娅回北卡罗来纳参加她母亲的葬礼时，他们不得不卖掉家里的骡子来支付旅费。但霍利斯说，不仅仅是费用的问题。
I reckon you'd be afraid, if you want to know the real word. I knew, according to the signs and things that they had in Opelousas, that the Dunbars were well-off people.
如果你想知道真实的情况，我觉得你应该会害怕。根据奥佩卢萨斯的标志和种种迹象，我知道邓巴一家是有钱人。
Dunbars everywhere.
到处都是邓巴。
Everywhere you look, there's a Dunbar sign on a building. They're something of the-- and people that has those signs up, I was always told that you didn't mess with them.
无论你往哪看，建筑上都有邓巴的标志。他们是某种……而且人们被告知，不要去招惹那些挂着标志的人。
And we figured if they took Mama's son, well, what kind of people were they to begin with?
我们觉得，如果他们能带走妈妈的儿子，那他们本身是什么样的人呢？
And if people can do that through the laws and get away with it, who are we to try to do or interfere with something like that?
如果人们能通过法律做到这一点并逍遥法外，我们又有什么能力去尝试干扰那样的事情呢？
For all the new things Margaret learned about Julia Anderson's family, one of the most surprising revelations Jewel and Hollis offered was about Margaret's grandfather. As much as the Andersons wondered about Bobby, it seemed he'd been wondering about them, as well.
对于玛格丽特从朱莉娅·安德森家学到的所有新东西，朱厄尔和霍利斯提供的一个最令人惊讶的启示是关于玛格丽特的祖父的。安德森一家对鲍比充满好奇，看来鲍比也一直对他们感到好奇。
Hollis remembers a day in 1944, maybe, when he was in his late 20s. He was working at an ice plant in Poplarville, and a man he'd never seen before came in and started making small talk. Finally, he introduced himself. He was Bobby Dunbar from Opelousas, Louisiana.
霍利斯记得1944年左右的一天，当时他快30岁了。他在波普拉维尔的一家制冰厂工作，一个他从未见过的人走进来，开始闲聊。最后，他介绍了自己。他就是路易斯安那州奥佩卢萨斯的鲍比·邓巴。
Hollis was startled. But before he could process it, a customer came in and Hollis had to rush off to work. When he came back, Bobby was still there. More small talk, and now a lot of looking each other over. But Hollis' work got in the way again, and eventually Bobby left.
霍利斯吓了一跳。但在他反应过来之前，一位顾客进来了，霍利斯不得不赶去工作。等他回来时，鲍比还在那里。更多的闲聊，现在是互相打量。但霍利斯的工作又成了阻碍，最后鲍比离开了。
But 30 minutes after he left, it dawned on me what I had done. Here was a man that I'd been looking for for 20, almost 30-- 20-something years, anyhow, and Mother had been telling me about. Here he is, looking me straight in the eye, and I didn't do nothing about trying to find out more about the situation. But I didn't. I just didn't, and I regret that.
但他离开30分钟后，我才意识到我做了什么。这正是我寻找了近20年、甚至快30年的那个人，母亲一直在跟我谈论的人。他就在这儿，直视着我的眼睛，我却什么都没做，没试着去了解更多情况。但我没有。我只是没做，我对此感到后悔。
Hollis' sister, Jewel, had a similar story. She was working at a service station that she and her husband ran at a crossroads outside Poplarville. A man came in and talked to her for maybe an hour, she says, just sat and drank coffee, looking only at her and asking all kinds of questions. But he didn't identify himself.
霍利斯的姐姐朱厄尔也有类似的故事。她在波普拉维尔外的一个十字路口经营一家加油站。她说，有一个男人进来了，和她谈了大约一个小时，只是坐着喝咖啡，一直盯着她看，问各种各样的问题。但他没有透露自己的身份。
After he left then and I got to thinking about it, I said, that is who I believe he was-- Bobby.
他走后，我开始琢磨，我说，我相信他就是那个人——鲍比。
When Margaret heard this story during her first visit with Hollis and Jewel back in 2000, she had her doubts. But later, Margaret was visiting with her uncle and aunt, her father's siblings. And while they were in the car, Margaret was telling them about her research and the mysterious encounters that Hollis and Jewel remembered. In the rear view mirror, she saw her uncle and aunt exchange a charged look. Then they told her this story. Here's Margaret's uncle, Gerald, Bobby Dunbar's youngest son.
玛格丽特在2000年第一次拜访霍利斯和朱厄尔时听到了这个故事，她当时还有些怀疑。但后来，玛格丽特去拜访了她的叔叔和阿姨，也就是她父亲的兄弟姐妹。当他们在车里时，玛格丽特向他们讲述了她的研究以及霍利斯和朱厄尔记得的那些神秘遭遇。在后视镜里，她看到叔叔和阿姨交换了一个意味深长的眼神。然后他们告诉了她这个故事。这是玛格丽特的叔叔杰拉尔德，鲍比·邓巴最小的儿子。
It would have been 1963, so I would have been 13 years old, right? We were coming back from a trip, my brother's wedding in Ohio, in Cincinnati. And on the way back, we went through Mississippi. And I remember my dad pointing. He says, those were the people that they came to pick me up from.
那应该是1963年，我当时13岁吧？我们从旅行回来，参加我哥哥在俄亥俄州辛辛那提的婚礼。在回来的路上，我们经过密西西比。我记得爸爸指着那里说，那些就是他们把我接走时所在的人家。
And he asked, he said, should I stop? And my mother sort of responded, if you think you should. And so they did. We stopped. Then he went into the store. And so we stayed there for maybe 30 minutes or so. And he came back, and we left.
他问，他说，我要停下来吗？我母亲随口回应道，如果你觉得应该的话。于是他们确实停下了。他走进商店。我们在那儿待了大概30分钟。他回来了，我们就离开了。
Margaret, the granddaughter of Bobby Dunbar, and Linda, the granddaughter of Julia Anderson, interpreted this eerie coincidence differently. They'd been discussing Margaret's research on the phone and online since they first met. On the one hand, they were ideal research partners since they both were singularly fascinated with the story. But on the other hand, it was an uneasy alliance. Here's Linda.
鲍比·邓巴的孙女玛格丽特和朱莉娅·安德森的孙女琳达，对这个令人毛骨悚然的巧合有着不同的解读。自第一次见面起，她们就在电话和网上讨论玛格丽特的研究。一方面，她们是理想的研究伙伴，因为她们都对这个故事有着极大的兴趣。但另一方面，这是一段不安的联盟。这是琳达。
Margaret was totally convinced that it was Bobby Dunbar all along. I was totally convinced that it was Bruce Anderson all along.
玛格丽特一直完全坚信那就是鲍比·邓巴。我则完全坚信那是布鲁斯·安德森。
We understood that we were both coming from different angles.
我们明白我们都是从不同的角度切入的。
Again, Margaret.
还是玛格丽特。
But what was there to do but butt heads, you know? And yet, we tried to do it very subtly for months.
但除了针锋相对，还能做什么呢，你知道吗？然而，几个月来，我们试图非常隐晦地处理这件事。
Good morning to everyone. And we are certainly glad to have all of you with us.
各位早安。我们非常高兴大家能和我们在一起。
Agreeing to disagree gets old fast. The differences between Margaret and Linda came to a head in Columbia, Mississippi, when Margaret was invited to share her research at the Historical Society in town. The sound you're hearing is from a video of the event. In the front of the room were Julia Anderson's children, Hollis and Jewel. Several times during her presentation, Margaret used phrases like this.
求同存异很快就会让人厌倦。当玛格丽特受邀在镇上的历史协会分享她的研究成果时，玛格丽特和琳达之间的分歧在密西西比州哥伦比亚市达到了顶峰。你听到的声音来自活动的录像。房间前排坐着朱莉娅·安德森的孩子们，霍利斯和朱厄尔。在演讲过程中，玛格丽特多次使用了这样的短语。
The illegitimate child of a domestic, Julia Anderson.
那个家佣朱莉娅·安德森的私生子。
The illegitimate child of a domestic, Julia Anderson. Jewel and Hollis bristled. That was their mom she was talking about. Margaret went on to describe Julia like a character in a story-- working in the fields with coarse hands and bare, dirty feet. And she made it clear that she didn't really believe the Anderson family's version of what happened, that Bobby was Bruce, but her own family's, that Bobby was Bobby, son of her great grandparents, Percy and Lessie Dunbar. When Jewel and Hollis got home and told Linda what happened, she got mad.
那个家佣朱莉娅·安德森的私生子。朱厄尔和霍利斯感到愤怒。她谈论的可是他们的妈妈。玛格丽特继续把朱莉娅描述成一个故事里的角色——用粗糙的手在田里工作，赤着又脏的脚。她明确表示，她并不真正相信安德森一家关于鲍比就是布鲁斯的说法，而是相信她自己家族的说法，即鲍比就是鲍比，是她曾祖父母珀西和莱西·邓巴的儿子。当朱厄尔和霍利斯回家并告诉琳达发生的事情时，她很生气。
I truly don't believe that, when she spoke and the way she spoke, I don't believe that she meant to say it to be as derogatory as we took it either, if you want to know the truth. She had spoken the truth of Julia Anderson had children out of wedlock. So she was a loose woman, which, if you have to accept that, you have to accept it.
我真心不认为，当她说话时，以及她说话的方式，如果想知道真相的话，我不认为她是带着我们感受到的那种贬义说的。她讲出的事实是朱莉娅·安德森在婚外生了孩子。所以她是个放荡的女人，如果你必须接受这一点，你就得接受。
But I wanted her to see it from my point of view, you know? I felt like she had looked at it from her point of view long enough, that it was my turn. And I don't remember if it was a written letter or email, but I told her, the very woman that you maligned at that meeting today could very well turn out to be your great grandmother.
但我希望她能从我的角度来看待这件事，你知道吗？我觉得她从她的角度看这个问题已经够久了，该轮到我了。我不记得那是书面信件还是电子邮件，但我告诉她，今天你在那次会议上诋毁的那位女性，很可能就是你的曾祖母。
She said to me--
她对我说——
Again, Margaret.
又是玛格丽特。
--you need to look a lot more closely. You keep wanting to know all about Julia. You need to look more into Lessie and Percy and judge their characters. And that did not make me happy. It sort of angered me to have her say that. But in retrospect, she was absolutely right. I did need to put down what I believed and be able to look at it with fresh eyes.
——你需要更仔细地观察。你一直想了解所有关于朱莉娅的事情。你需要更多地研究莱西和珀西，判断他们的品格。这让我很不高兴。有人那样说让我感到生气。但回想起来，她是完全正确的。我确实需要放下我所相信的东西，用全新的眼光去看待它。
Coming up, what Margaret discovers. Plus, the kidnapper speaks. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，玛格丽特发现了什么。此外，绑架者开口了。稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our story unraveling the century-old mystery of what happened to Bobby Dunbar continues. Again, here's Tal McThenia.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们关于解开鲍比·邓巴失踪百年谜团的故事继续进行。再次，这是塔尔·麦克塞尼亚。
By 2003, Margaret had been researching for four years. She'd taken all the articles from the scrapbook and all the articles from all the libraries and typed them, over 1,200 total. Margaret had maps, and photo albums, and tape recordings, and books on her shelf like, Social History of the American Alligator. That year, she started looking for descendants of William Walters, the wandering handyman, the man who'd kidnapped her grandfather.
到2003年，玛格丽特已经研究了四年。她把剪贴簿里的所有文章和所有图书馆里的所有文章都进行了打字整理，总计超过1200篇。玛格丽特有地图、相册、录音带，书架上有像《美洲鳄社会史》这样的书。那年，她开始寻找威廉·沃尔特斯的后代，那个流浪的杂工，绑架她祖父的男人。
In 1914, Walters was convicted of kidnapping Bobby Dunbar. His lawyers appealed, and the state supreme court ordered a retrial. But incredibly, because the first trial cost the town so much money, prosecutors decided to drop the case instead. Walters was released.
1914年，沃尔特斯因绑架鲍比·邓巴被判有罪。他的律师上诉，州最高法院下令重审。但令人难以置信的是，因为第一次审判让小镇花费了太多钱，检察官决定撤诉。沃尔特斯被释放了。
In 2003, Margaret opened up something called the Walters Family Genealogy Book. She pored over the names in the book and started making phone calls.
2003年，玛格丽特打开了一本名为《沃尔特斯家族族谱》的书。她仔细研读了书中的名字，开始拨打电话。
I'm Jean Cooper, and I'm the great niece of William Cantwell Walters. We always called him Uncle Cant. I never knew he had a William Cantwell until all this came up. He was always Uncle Cant.
我是简·库珀，我是威廉·坎特威尔·沃尔特斯的侄孙女。我们一直叫他坎特叔叔。直到这一切出现，我才知道他叫威廉·坎特威尔。他总是坎特叔叔。
We met with Jean and her sister Barbara in Savannah, Georgia. Just like Hollis and Jewel and Margaret, they'd grown up hearing the Bobby Dunbar story, too, only their version was a little racier.
我们在乔治亚州的萨凡纳见到了简和她的姐姐芭芭拉。就像霍利斯、朱厄尔和玛格丽特一样，她们从小也听过鲍比·邓巴的故事，只是她们的版本稍微生动一些。
Well, the story we heard was that this Miss Julia Anderson was a fine young lady. But you know, mostly, fine young ladies get entrapped. And I'll tell you what, there's many a handsome, young, sweet-talking man come around and entrapped them. So that's what happened to Miss Julia, as the story went.
嗯，我们听到的故事是，那位朱莉娅·安德森小姐是一位好姑娘。但你知道，大多数好姑娘都会落入圈套。我告诉你，有很多英俊、年轻、甜言蜜语的男人出现并陷害她们。所以这就是朱莉娅小姐身上发生的事情，正如传说所说。
Now, I know it was rumored that Uncle Cant was the father and that one of his brothers was the father. It could have been Uncle Bunt. He was a rounder. He was a real rounder. But they all denied it. They said it was another feller.
现在，我知道有传言说坎特叔叔是生父，或者他的一个兄弟是生父。可能是邦特叔叔。他是个浪子。他真是个浪子。但他们都否认了。他们说是另一个人。
Jean and Barbara grew up on a farm in Georgia with their ailing grandfather, Rad, William Walter's brother. After getting released from jail, William Walters had gone back to his life as a tinker, a traveling handyman, tuning pianos in people's parlors and fixing organs in country churches. And at least once or twice a year, his travels would bring him around to his brother's house for a visit.
简和芭芭拉在乔治亚州的一个农场长大，照顾她们生病的祖父拉德，也就是威廉·沃尔特斯的兄弟。被释放出狱后，威廉·沃尔特斯又回到了他修补匠的生活中，成了一名流浪的杂工，在人们的客厅里调钢琴，在乡村教堂修理风琴。每年至少一两次，他的旅行会让他来到兄弟家探亲。
Seeing Uncle Cant come with his wagon a-trinkling and a-bouncing, the pots and pans a-bouncing against each other, you couldn't help but know it was Uncle Cant. But Grandpa would lighten up. Oh, he would just brighten up. There's Cant. There's Cant. Young'uns, put some more wood on the fire. Go see what's in the kitchen. Fix him some supper. He'd always come about dark. Every time I remember him coming, it was about dark, wasn't it, Barbie?
看着坎特叔叔赶着他的马车叮当作响，锅碗瓢盆互相碰撞，你不可能不知道那是坎特叔叔。但祖父会很高兴。哦，他会变得非常开朗。那是坎特。那是坎特。孩子们，往火里多加点柴。去看看厨房里有什么。给他做点晚饭。他总是天黑时来。每次记得他来的时候，都是天黑，对吧，芭比？
Yeah, night.
是的，晚上。
And it didn't matter if we'd already had supper and the fire had gone out in the stove. We had to light up the fire and fix Uncle Cant some supper so he could sit with Grandpa till midnight. But each and every time he'd come-- and he would come several times a year and stay a month at the time, or three, two to four weeks-- they sat and talked over the case of the kidnapping and how innocent he was. It was like it had just happened.
无论我们是否已经吃了晚饭，炉子里的火是否熄灭都无所谓。我们必须点火，给坎特叔叔准备晚饭，这样他就可以和祖父坐到午夜。但每一次他来——他每年会来几次，每次住上一个月，或者三、两到四周——他们坐在一起谈论那起绑架案，以及他是多么无辜。就好像刚刚发生一样。
During one visit, Jean and Barbara's grandfather asked William Walters what he was doing traveling around the country with somebody else's boy in the first place. Walters explained that Julia was in dire straits, and she couldn't take care of Bruce. And he was planning on bringing the boy back once she got on her feet. And also, there was the business element.
在一次拜访中，简和芭芭拉的祖父问威廉·沃尔特斯，为什么他一开始会带着别人的孩子到处旅行。沃尔特斯解释说，朱莉娅处于绝境，她无法照顾布鲁斯。他打算等她站稳脚跟后就把孩子送回去。而且，还有商业因素。
Uncle Cant told Grandpa that, with that little boy with him, people were a lot nicer when he stopped to spend the night. Because he would stop along the road at farm houses and around in his travels and ask for a night's lodging and hay for the horses. And then he would do things for them-- tune their pianos, organs, or whatever. And he said, with that little boy, the mothers just couldn't wait to get their hands on the little boy and feed him, and cuddle him, and bathe him.
坎特叔叔告诉祖父，带着那个小男孩，他停下过夜时人们会好客得多。因为他在旅行途中会在农舍附近停下来，寻求一晚的住宿和给马吃的干草。然后他会为他们做些事情——调钢琴、风琴之类的。他说，有了那个小男孩，母亲们简直迫不及待地想亲手喂他、拥抱他、给他洗澡。
In fact, a woman told me one time she had a neighbor-- if I'm getting off the beaten path, but it'll kind of explain it-- that was ugly as homemade sin. And she was all the time wanting to take her little grandchild with her everywhere, shopping, and to the grocery store, and walking. And I said, well, why does she want to carry him along with her all the time? She says, well, she is so ugly it makes her look better to have a little child along with her.
事实上，有一次一个女人告诉我有邻居——如果我偏离了轨道，但这能解释它——那邻居丑得像自作自受。她总是想带着小孙子去任何地方，逛街、去杂货店、散步。我说，好吧，为什么她总是想带着他？她说，嗯，她太丑了，带个小孩子会让看起来好一点。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So that could have been Uncle Cant having that little child, especially the ladies in the house were a lot nicer.
所以带着那个小孩子可能是坎特叔叔的计策，特别是在屋里的女士们会更友善。
This is the defense file. These are photocopies.
这是辩护卷宗。这些是复印件。
Margaret had also tracked down the granddaughter of William Walters' lawyer, who had saved in a closet the complete defense file from the kidnapping case. When Margaret heard that, she dropped everything, bought a portable scanner, and showed up at the woman's doorstep. She spent a week scanning the entire thing and then four months back at home typing and deciphering it.
玛格丽特还追踪到了威廉·沃尔特斯律师的孙女，她把绑架案的完整辩护卷宗保存在衣柜里。玛格丽特听说后，放下了一切，买了一台便携式扫描仪，出现在那女人的家门口。她花了一周时间扫描了全部内容，然后回家花了四个月时间打字和破译它。
The defense file was a gold mine. It had correspondence from the governors of Mississippi and Louisiana, handwritten letters from Julia Anderson, and dozens of sworn affidavits from Mississippi residents saying that the child was Bruce Anderson and that they'd seen him in the area with Walters months before Bobby Dunbar went missing. And then there was this letter, written by William Walters himself just days after he was arrested and thrown in jail, addressed directly to Percy Dunbar, who had just taken the boy home with him.
辩护卷宗是个金矿。它有来自密西西比和路易斯安那州州长的通信，朱莉娅·安德森的亲笔信，以及几十份密西西比居民的宣誓书，称孩子就是布鲁斯·安德森，而且早在鲍比·邓巴失踪几个月前，他们就见过他和沃尔特斯在该地区活动。还有这封信，是威廉·沃尔特斯本人在被捕入狱几天后写的，直接写给珀西·邓巴，他刚刚把孩子带回家。
"I see that you got Bruce, but you have heaped up trouble for yourselves. I had no chance to prove up, but I know by now you have decided you are wrong. It is very likely I will lose my life on account of that. And if I do, the great God will hold you accountable.
“我看到你带走了布鲁斯，但你给自己堆积了麻烦。我没有机会证明，但我知道现在你已经决定自己错了。我很有可能因为那个而丧命。如果我真的死了，伟大的上帝会让你负责。”
That boy's mother is Julia Anderson. You ask him, and he will tell you. I did not teach him to beg or bum. But in as much as you have him, take good care of him. So you have a lost Robert and me a lost Bruce. May God bless my darling boy. Write me, if I don't get lynched. I think you will be sad a long time, but hope not too bad."
“那个男孩的母亲是朱莉娅·安德森。你问他，他会告诉你的。我没有教他乞讨。但既然你留着他，请照顾好他。你失去了一个罗伯特，我也失去了一个布鲁斯。愿上帝保佑我亲爱的孩子。如果不被私刑处死，写信给我。我想你会难过很久，但愿不会太糟。”
The defense file was 400 pages of evidence that directly challenged Margaret's family legend. And pretty soon, Margaret reached a breaking point.
辩护卷宗有400页的证据，直接挑战了玛格丽特的家族传奇。很快，玛格丽特达到了临界点。
Toward the very end of me typing the defense file, which was not in chronological order, I came across a letter that totally-- it was my epiphany. It was a letter written by a Christian woman. I don't even know her name. She just signed it "A Christian Woman." And it was written to the attorneys of William Walters.
在我打完辩护卷宗快结束时，由于这些不是按时间顺序排列的，我偶然发现了一封信，它完全……这是我的顿悟。这是一封由一位基督教妇女写的信。我甚至不知道她的名字。她只署名“一位基督教妇女”。它是写给威廉·沃尔特斯的律师的。
And it says, "Kindly pardon me. I am ill in bed. But this matter has just worried me. Dear sir, in view of human justice to Julia Anderson and mothers, I am prompted to write to you. I sincerely believe the Dunbars have Bruce Anderson and not their boy. If this is their child, why are they afraid for anyone to see or interview him privately? I would see nothing to fear, and this seems strange. The Dunbars claim that--"
它写道：“请原谅我。我病倒在床。但这事让我很担心。亲爱的先生，鉴于对朱莉娅·安德森和母亲们的人性公正，我深受感动给您写信。我真诚地相信邓巴一家带走的是布鲁斯·安德森，而不是他们自己的男孩。如果这是他们的孩子，为什么他们害怕让任何人私下看到或采访他？我看不出有什么好怕的，这看起来很奇怪。邓巴一家声称——”
The letter goes on for six pages, laying out a point-by-point, common sense argument that the Dunbars have the wrong child. Why haven't pictures of Bobby and Bruce been printed side by side so the world could see whether they look alike or not? Why is Julia judged more harshly for wavering than Lessie, when neither of them recognized the child at first? Which gets A Christian Woman to her biggest point-- a look back at that fateful night in Mississippi when the Dunbars first saw the boy and didn't recognize him, until Lessie gave him a bath and saw his moles and scars.
这封信写了六页纸，一点一点地提出了一个常识性论点，即邓巴一家找错了孩子。为什么鲍比和布鲁斯的照片没有被并排打印出来，好让全世界看看他们长得像不像？为什么人们对朱莉娅的动摇判断得比莱西更严厉，而她们最初都没认出孩子？这让“一位基督教妇女”得出了她最大的观点——回顾密西西比那个决定性的夜晚，当时邓巴一家第一次见到男孩时没认出他，直到莱西给他洗了澡，看到了他的痣和伤疤。
"If this had been their own child and he had been gone eight months, do you think his features would be so changed that they would not know him only by moles and scars? This is a farce. If the Dunbars do not know their child who has only been gone eight months by his features, why, they don't know him at all."
“如果这是他们自己的孩子，他已经失踪八个月了，你认为他的外貌会改变到他们只能通过痣和伤疤才能认出他的程度吗？这是一场闹剧。如果邓巴一家都认不出失踪仅八个月的自己的孩子，那他们根本就不了解他。”
Reason, by reason, by reason, this woman is giving me every-- she apparently followed this very closely in the newspapers. And it just simply dawned on me, oh, my god, she's right. What a farce. What a farce this is.
理由，理由，理由，这个女人给了我一切……她显然非常密切地关注报纸。我突然意识到，天哪，她是对的。多么荒谬。这太荒谬了。
The idea for a DNA test had been floating around for years, but Margaret hadn't wanted to do it unless all her uncles and aunts, Bobby Dunbar's children, agreed to it. And then, four years into her research, a reporter from the Associated Press, Allen Breed, got wind of the story. Margaret remembers being in the room when Allen asked her father if he would consent to a DNA test. She was startled at his answer. Yes, he said. He wanted to do it now. He'd waited long enough.
进行DNA测试的想法已经浮现多年，但除非她所有的叔叔阿姨，也就是鲍比·邓巴的孩子们都同意，否则玛格丽特不想做。然后，在她的研究进行到第四年时，美联社的一名记者艾伦·布里德听说了这个故事。玛格丽特记得当艾伦问她父亲是否同意进行DNA测试时，她就在房间里。他回答时她吃了一惊。是的，他说。他想现在就做。他等得够久了。
Margaret's father, Bob Dunbar, Jr., was Bobby Dunbar's oldest son. He'd heard the legend, of course, but he'd never heard it from his father.
玛格丽特的父亲，小鲍勃·邓巴，是鲍比·邓巴的长子。他当然听过那个传奇，但他从没听父亲提起过。
It was not something that we discussed at home. It was just the stuff was in the attic-- newspaper articles, some pictures. It was stuff that my mother gathered. At home, we never discussed it.
这不是我们在家讨论的事情。东西都在阁楼里——报纸文章，一些照片。那是我母亲收集的东西。在家里，我们从不讨论。
But Bob had been watching Margaret's research with interest. Remember, he'd given her the scrapbook that got this whole thing started. Bob had just spent weeks in the hospital with congestive heart failure and explained his decision this way, in a letter to his family. "Daddy did not have the science of DNA to confirm the decision of the court in his youth. I feel it is my responsibility to achieve that before I go."
但鲍勃一直很有兴趣地关注着玛格丽特的研究。记住，是他给了她那本启动这一切的剪贴簿。鲍勃刚因充血性心力衰竭在医院住了几周，他在给家人的信中这样解释了他的决定。“爸爸年轻时没有DNA科学来证实法庭的判决。我觉得在我离开之前，我有责任去实现这一点。”
The easiest way to do the test would be to compare the DNA of two different lines of Dunbars, someone from Bobby's line, since his identity was in doubt, and someone from his brother Alonzo's line, since there was no question he was a Dunbar.
做测试最简单的方法是比较两条不同的邓巴血脉的DNA，一条来自鲍比的，因为他的身份存疑，另一条来自他兄弟阿隆佐的，因为毫无疑问他是邓巴。
Bob and Margaret spoke with Alonzo's son, David, and he agreed to do the test. The plan was to keep the results sealed until all Bob's siblings agreed to open them. A month passed.
鲍勃和玛格丽特与阿隆佐的儿子大卫谈过，他同意进行测试。计划是在所有鲍勃的兄弟姐妹同意公开之前，将结果密封。一个月过去了。
I called to check with the laboratory, and the laboratory assistant ended up blurting to me the results over the phone. The DNA did not match. You know, as far as she was concerned, it was a paternity test. She had no idea the impact of what she was saying to me. It was a shock to me, not really the conclusion, but to hear it.
我打电话去实验室核实，实验室助理最终在电话里冲口说出了结果。DNA不匹配。你知道，在她看来，这只是个亲子鉴定。她根本不知道她对我说的话有什么影响。我感到震惊，不是对结论，而是听到这个事实。
Margaret got off the phone and drove 10 hours that day to tell her father in person. He was still in the hospital.
玛格丽特挂断电话，那天开了10个小时的车，当面告诉了她父亲。他还在医院。
It took my breath away. You know, I hadn't considered that. My thought was to prove that Daddy was Bobby Dunbar. So it took me-- well, I had a lot of time. I was in the hospital a while. And I just pondered, you know? All right, if my past is wrong-- Bobby Dunbar, all the legends, all the stories-- and then all of the sudden you find out, well, that's not who your blood says you are. Where does that leave me? If my grandpa isn't my grandpa, who am I?
这让我喘不过气来。你知道，我没考虑过这点。我的想法是证明爸爸就是鲍比·邓巴。所以我花了……好吧，我有很多时间。我在医院待了一阵子。我只是在思考，你知道吗？好吧，如果我的过去是错的——鲍比·邓巴，所有的传奇，所有的故事——然后突然间你发现，好吧，你的血液里并不是那样的人。那让我处于什么境地？如果我爷爷不是我爷爷，我是谁？
Bob's siblings had no idea he'd taken the test. And that an AP reporter was preparing to write an article for the National Wire. Bob had to tell them. And when he did, they were all stunned and really mad-- mad at Bob, but especially mad at Margaret, who they blamed for orchestrating the whole thing and making it national news. Margaret's younger brother, Swin, explained what it was like.
鲍勃的兄弟姐妹不知道他做了测试。而且一位美联社记者正准备为全国电讯社写一篇文章。鲍勃不得不告诉他们。当他说出这件事时，他们全都惊呆了，而且非常愤怒——对鲍勃感到愤怒，但尤其是对玛格丽特，他们责怪她策划了这一切并使其成为全国新闻。玛格丽特年轻的弟弟斯温解释了当时的情况。
You know, she was really going up against the entire family, including myself. In fact, I'm not sure of any family member that was for it, except for her and possibly my dad. And in retrospect, you know, she was doing what she felt was right. But I felt like she was alienating everybody else in doing so.
你知道，她确实是在和整个家庭作对，包括我在内。事实上，我不确定有哪个家庭成员支持，除了她和可能还有我爸爸。回想起来，你知道，她在做她认为正确的事情。但我感觉她在这样做时疏远了其他人。
The other thing about all that is some of us in the family, and probably even me at one time, probably felt like she was being a little bit selfish, you know? Why do this? Why do you need to do this? Nobody in the family wants to know.
关于这一切的另一件事是，我们家族中的一些人，可能甚至连我也曾有过一次，可能觉得她有点自私，你知道吗？为什么要做这个？你为什么非要这么做？家里没人想知道。
After the story ran in 2004, a thick silence descended between Margaret and her relatives. And that schism has persisted to this day. When she told them I'd called her about doing this radio story, the relatives were furious. They told Margaret that, yet again, she'd proven that she couldn't be trusted. They said she was disrespecting their heritage and destroying family relationships. They told her that they were Dunbars, and that's all they wanted to be.
故事在2004年发表后，玛格丽特和她的亲戚之间降下了一层厚厚的沉默。这种分裂一直持续到今天。当她告诉他们我因为做这个广播故事给她打电话时，亲戚们非常愤怒。他们告诉玛格丽特，她再次证明了她不可信任。他们说她不尊重他们的血统，破坏了家庭关系。他们告诉她，他们是邓巴一家，这就是他们想成为的一切。
But the other two families involved took it a little better. For Jean and Barbara Cooper, the great-nieces of William Walters, it meant their ancestor wasn't a kidnapper, which was nice to hear.
但涉及到的另外两个家庭处理得好一些。对于威廉·沃尔特斯的侄孙女简和芭芭拉·库珀来说，这意味着她们的祖先不是绑架者，这听起来很不错。
You don't like to think of your people being guilty of something like that. And I don't think we had many people, did we, that was falsely accused.
你不希望想到你的人会犯下那种事。我不认为我们有很多人，对吧，被错误指控了。
The ones that were accused were usually guilty.
那些被指控的人通常是有罪的。
And proven so.
并且被证明了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And for the Andersons, it was literally the answer to a lifetime of prayers. Margaret's father, Bob, and his wife, Imelda, went down to Mississippi to deliver the news in person to Linda, Jewel, and Hollis.
而对于安德森一家来说，这简直是终身祈祷的答案。玛格丽特的父亲鲍勃和他的妻子伊梅尔达去密西西比亲自把这个消息告诉琳达、朱厄尔和霍利斯。
We didn't know what was up. They said, be there. We have some--
我们不知道是怎么回事。他们说，去那儿。我们有一些——
No, they didn't tell us.
不，他们没告诉我们。
They wouldn't tell us what, till got to the meeting. And he told us that the DNA had been run, and that he was not a Dunbar, you know? And that's where the eyes-- you know, we all just-- I got up from where we were sitting on the couch, and I went around, and I think I hugged his neck, just knowing that, man, we were family. We were just family.
直到见面之前，他们什么都没说。他告诉我们DNA已经跑出来了，他不是邓巴，你知道吗？那就是……你知道，我们全都在那儿……我从沙发上站起来，走到他身后，我想我拥抱了他的脖子，只是知道，伙计，我们是家人。我们就是一家人。
When Bobby Jr. and Miss Imelda came and they told us about the DNA testing, that's the day Bobby came home. And he came in the form of his son. And we were proud for Julia. The one thing she wanted most in her life was her child back, and she got him.
当小鲍勃和伊梅尔达夫人来告诉我们关于DNA测试的事情时，那是鲍比回家的那一天。他以他儿子的形式回来了。我们为朱莉娅感到骄傲。她一生中最想要的就是要把孩子找回来，而她做到了。
I told him that day. I said, now, we're not expecting nothing from them, but friendship. That's all that we ever wanted.
那天我告诉他。我说，现在，除了友谊，我们不指望他们任何东西。那就是我们一直想要的。
We have no hard feelings against nobody of what has happened. Because back in those days, I am sure they thought they were doing the right thing. And if I'd have been back in those days, I might have felt the same way in a way about some things like that. I don't know. But now, we're just happy about the situation, but not happy they're unhappy, if you know what I'm talking about. We're just happy because we know the truth now.
我们对发生的任何事情都不对任何人怀有怨恨。因为在那些日子里，我相信他们认为自己是在做正确的事。如果我当时身处那个时代，关于某些事情，我可能也会有同样的感觉。我不知道。但现在，我们只是对现状感到高兴，而不是因为他们不高兴而高兴，如果你知道我在说什么的话。我们只是很高兴，因为我们现在知道真相了。
Let's see. We're coming up-- we're getting closer to where my grandmother lived and my grandfather. Oh my gosh, it was this house right here.
让我们看看。我们正在接近……我们离我祖母和祖父住的地方越来越近了。天哪，就是这座房子。
Margaret's taking me on a driving tour of Opelousas. She grew up spending summer vacations here at her grandmother's with her whole family. It's a mix of personal history and history she's read about in her research. We go by the public pool where she used to spend afternoons swimming and hanging out and also the old jail site where William Walters played a homemade harp to the crowds outside his cell window.
玛格丽特正带我进行奥佩卢萨斯的自驾游。她从小就和全家人在祖母家度过暑假。这是个人历史与她在研究中读到的历史的结合。我们路过她过去经常游泳和消磨时光的公共泳池，以及威廉·沃尔特斯在他的牢房窗外为外面的人群演奏自制竖琴的旧监狱遗址。
We want to turn left.
我们想左转。
We drive into a subdivision that her great uncle Alonzo developed-- sprawling ranches, big lawns, strange street names.
我们开车进入了一个她叔祖父阿隆佐开发的住宅区——蔓延的牧场风格房屋、大草坪、奇怪的街道名称。
Yeah. And he named some of these streets, like this one was named after himself. And he named one called Anna Lee, after his wife. And there's one called Dunbar Street, which here we are at Dunbar Street.
是的。他给这些街道起了一些名字，就像这一条是以他自己命名的。他以妻子的名字命名了一条叫安娜·李的街道。还有一条叫邓巴街，我们现在就在邓巴街。
There are still Dunbars in Opelousas, relatives that Margaret knows and loves, but she doesn't feel comfortable bringing me in for a visit. We're tiptoeing around. Margaret's cigarette breaks are happening more and more frequently. The contrast between the tension in Opelousas and the welcome she'd received two days ago from the Andersons in Poplarville is hard to miss.
奥佩卢萨斯仍然有邓巴一家，玛格丽特认识并爱着的一些亲戚，但她觉得带我进去拜访并不自在。我们正小心翼翼地走着。玛格丽特的吸烟休息变得越来越频繁。奥佩卢萨斯的紧张气氛与两天前她在波普拉维尔受到的安德森一家的欢迎之间的反差很难被忽视。
Julia Anderson's children have done nothing but welcome and embrace me into their lives. And they think that I'm brave and smart. And William Walters' family thinks that I'm a whiz. [LAUGHS]
朱莉娅·安德森的孩子们除了欢迎和拥抱我进入他们的生活，什么也没做。他们认为我勇敢又聪明。威廉·沃尔特斯的家人认为我是个天才。[笑声]
I think, for my family, when I started this project, I thought that this would sort of keep us bonded, and it didn't. It divided. So in a way, I feel like a failure. There are people upset by it. And there are some people who still don't accept the truth. It's like they don't believe me. They don't believe me.
我想，对于我的家人来说，当我开始这个项目时，我以为这会让我们保持紧密，但并没有。它导致了分裂。所以在某种程度上，我觉得自己是个失败者。有人因此感到难过。还有一些人仍然不接受真相。就像他们不相信我。他们不相信我。
The disappearance of Bobby Dunbar blew apart the lives of three different families. But the people you'd think would be hurt the worst by it actually come out the best, like Julia Anderson. Before Bobby's disappearance, she was a field hand in North Carolina, on her own, not making enough money to feed her own child. The people she worked for mistreated her. The man she married shot her in the foot the night after her wedding. But William Walters' kidnapping trial got her out of there to a better place-- Poplarville, Mississippi.
鲍比·邓巴的失踪摧毁了三个不同家庭的生活。但你认为会因此受害最深的人实际上得到了最好的结果，比如朱莉娅·安德森。在鲍比失踪前，她是北卡罗来纳州的一名田间劳工，独自一人，挣的钱不够养活自己的孩子。她工作的人虐待她。她嫁的男人在婚后第一天晚上开枪射中了她的脚。但威廉·沃尔特斯的绑架案审判让她离开了那里，去了一个更好的地方——密西西比州波普拉维尔。
Back in 1912 and 1913, William Walters and Julia's son, Bruce, had been well-known fixtures in the Poplarville area. He and Bruce stayed in people's homes for weeks at a time while he tuned pianos and repaired the church organ. And when William Walters went to trial, these very people-- at least 20 of them-- came forward to testify to his innocence. And that's where they met Julia, the mother of the child they'd known and cared for, who was also there to testify for Walters.
早在1912年和1913年，威廉·沃尔特斯和朱莉娅的儿子布鲁斯就是波普拉维尔地区众所周知的常客。他和布鲁斯有时在人们家里住上几周，而他调钢琴、修理教堂风琴。当威廉·沃尔特斯受审时，这些人——至少有20个——站出来为他的清白作证。就在那时，他们遇到了朱莉娅，那个他们熟知并关心的孩子的母亲，她也在那里为沃尔特斯作证。
After the trial, Julia had no money and no place to go. The people from Mississippi took her in.
审判后，朱莉娅没有钱，也没有地方去。密西西比的人们接纳了她。
It was almost like she was adopted just like Bruce was taken in to be Bobby. And both of them were given a new life. I mean, everything bad could be said about somebody was said about Julia. At this trial, you know, everything that could be said was said.
就像布鲁斯被领养成为鲍比一样，她几乎也被领养了。他们俩都获得了新生。我的意思是，关于某人所能说的一切坏话都被用在朱莉娅身上了。在这次审判中，你知道，所有能说的话都被说了。
But these people saw something in her, or they wouldn't have taken her in their home. Yeah, the people here in Poplarville out at Ford's Creek. They could have left her in Opelousas. They could've left her in New Orleans, but they brought her home with them.
但这些人从她身上看到了什么，否则他们不会把她带到自己家里。是的，波普拉维尔福德溪的这些人。他们本可以把她留在奥佩卢萨斯。他们本可以把她留在新奥尔良，但他们把她带回家了。
She lost everything. She had a baby that died just before she came down here, you know? And now she's lost Bruce. What did she have to live for? Suicide was not unheard of, you know? I'm sure they didn't promise her-- they just said, come home with us. Come home with us till you get on your feet. Come home with us till you can get up and do for yourself.
她失去了一切。她刚来这里之前有个婴儿去世了，你知道吗？现在她又失去了布鲁斯。她还有什么值得活下去的？自杀并非闻所未闻，你知道吗？我敢肯定他们没有向她承诺什么——他们只是说，跟我们回家。跟我们回家，直到你站稳脚跟。跟我们回家，直到你能自己照顾自己。
So I can't regret it. I cannot regret for one minute that she came down here. I'm sad that she did not have that child. And I don't believe that she would ever made-- given the opportunity of saying, OK, we'll give you a new life if you'll give us this child, she would have never given that child up. I don't believe that.
所以我不能后悔。我一分钟都不能后悔她来到这里。我为她没能得到那个孩子感到难过。我不相信她会……如果得到机会说，好吧，我们会给你一个新的生活，如果你把这个孩子给我们，她是永远不会放弃那个孩子的。我不相信那样。
But if you hate that it happened, then you hate that you are, if that makes any sense. And I don't hate that I am. I rejoice in that I am. I rejoice in the family that we've got. And I feel like Grandmother felt the same way.
但如果你憎恨发生过的事，那你就是在憎恨你自己的存在，如果这说得通的话。我不憎恨我自己的存在。我为自己的存在感到欣喜。我为我们拥有的家庭感到欣喜。我觉得祖母也有同样的感觉。
As for the consequences for Bobby, even Julia Anderson's children, Hollis and Jewel, figure he was probably better off with the Dunbars.
至于对鲍比的影响，即使是朱莉娅·安德森的孩子霍利斯和朱厄尔也认为，他跟着邓巴一家可能更好。
I don't want to put him down or my mother down, either, you know what I mean? She did the best she could with what probably she had to do with. But here's some people that-- he got off the wagon to get in a car.
我不想贬低他，也不想贬低我母亲，你知道我的意思吗？她尽她所能做了她不得不做的事。但这里有一些人——他从马车上下来，坐进了汽车里。
"Enclosed are the divorce papers I promised you. I know that these are official copies because the notary seals are raised."
“随信附上我承诺给你的离婚协议。我知道这些是正式副本，因为公证印章是凸起的。”
The divorce papers of Percy and Lessie Dunbar are brief, but even the bare facts are enough to imagine what life in the Dunbar family was like for Bobby after the trial. Lessie and Percy separated in 1920, meaning five years after the court affirmed that Bobby was hers, Lessie left him, her husband, and her other son, Alonzo, behind and moved to New Orleans. Bobby was 12, and Alonzo was 10.
珀西和莱西·邓巴的离婚协议很简短，但即使是基本事实也足以想象在审判后，鲍比在邓巴家庭的生活是什么样的。莱西和珀西于1920年分居，这意味着在法庭确认鲍比是她儿子的五年后，莱西留下了他、她的丈夫和另一个儿子阿隆佐，搬到了新奥尔良。鲍比12岁，阿隆佐10岁。
Also in 1920, Percy beat and stabbed a man while on a trip to Florida on the eighth anniversary of the day of Bobby's disappearance. His court record for this assault is included in the divorce papers. Lessie makes accusations of repeated and ongoing infidelity, but Percy denies the charges. Elsewhere, there is another court record that corroborates Lessie's claim. It's an arrest record for Percy on charges of adultery and cohabitation. But perhaps the most compelling detail is a handwritten note that accompanies the packet. It's from Lessie herself to Elizabeth, her granddaughter who took care of her in her old age.
同样在1920年，珀西在鲍比失踪八周年纪念日那天去佛罗里达旅行时殴打并刺伤了一名男子。他因这次袭击的法庭记录被包含在离婚协议中。莱西指控他反复且持续地不忠，但珀西否认了这些指控。在其他地方，还有一份法庭记录证实了莱西的说法。那是一份珀西因通奸和非法同居被捕的记录。但也许最引人注目的细节是随信附上的一张手写便条。它是莱西本人写给伊丽莎白的，伊丽莎白是她晚年照顾她的孙女。
This says, "For Elizabeth Dunbar to read after my death so she may know why I stayed in my shell of grief."
上面写着，“留给伊丽莎白·邓巴在我死后阅读，这样她就能知道我为什么一直待在悲伤的壳里。”
She stayed in her shell of grief?
很难直面这一点。这样做使玛格丽特和她的父亲鲍勃与家族的其他成员产生了矛盾。但鲍勃说，只有直面它，才能看到他们家族故事中的救赎。
I think she had to have, on some level, known. And maybe she didn't. I don't know. I think maybe she was in a denial her entire life. From everything I've heard, she truly believed that this was her son, Bobby. But I can't help but wonder that maybe, underneath, where you go and can't talk about, she must have known that this was not her son that she birthed.
我想她在某种程度上一定是知道的。也许她不知道。我不知道。我想也许她一生都在否认。从我听到的所有消息来看，她确实相信这就是她的儿子鲍比。但我禁不住怀疑，也许在内心深处，无法言说的某个地方，她一定知道这不是她亲生的儿子。
And this is probably at the heart of the Dunbar family's unhappiness with this story, what it suggests about their ancestors and their ancestors' motives and characters.
这可能就是邓巴家族对这个故事不满的核心，它暗示了他们的祖先及其动机和品格。
It's likely to me that Percy must have known somewhere inside of him that this little boy he took from Mississippi was not his son. And I don't say that lightly. It took me a long time to come to that conclusion.
我觉得珀西在内心深处一定知道，他从密西西比带回的这个小男孩不是他的儿子。我不是随便说的。我花了很长时间才得出这个结论。
After reading all of the articles and the court records, these divorce papers, I realized that if he was capable of doing these things, if Percy was capable-- if he could stab a man, if he could be with another woman while he was married-- you know, he lies in these papers. Could he lie about this child? Did he lie about this child? He had a motive to save his wife's sanity. Could he do that? I think he could. I think he did.
在阅读了所有的文章和法庭记录、这些离婚协议后，我意识到，如果他有能力做这些事，如果珀西有能力——如果他能刺伤一个人，如果他能在已婚时与另一个女人在一起——你知道，他在这些文件中撒了谎。关于这个孩子，他能撒谎吗？关于这个孩子，他撒谎了吗？他有动机去挽救他妻子的理智。他能做到吗？我认为他能。我认为他做了。
It's hard to look square in the face of this. And doing so has put Margaret and her father, Bob, at odds with the rest of their family. But Bob says, only by looking at it squarely can you see the redemption in their family story.
面对这种情况，很难直视事实。而这样做使玛格丽特和她的父亲鲍勃与家中其他人产生了分歧。但鲍勃说，只有正视它，才能看到他们家族故事中的救赎。
When Bobby Dunbar was 18, he fell in love with a girl from a nearby town. It took him nine years to get her to marry him, but once she did, they raised four children, who all remember a very happy upbringing, full of love. And Bobby Dunbar gave rise to this family despite all that he'd been through-- whisked away from his mother at three, living in a wagon with an old man, huddling by fires in the woods at night, a two-year-long gauntlet of undressing, and parading, and sobbing, and staring. And when that was all over, his new family fractured and fell apart. And once again, he was abandoned. To come out of that, to create a family after that, to Bob, is a story of triumph.
鲍比·邓巴18岁时，爱上了邻镇的一个女孩。他花了九年时间才娶到她，但一旦结婚，他们抚养了四个孩子，他们都记得有一个非常幸福的成长环境，充满爱。尽管经历了这一切，鲍比·邓巴还是建立起了这个家庭——三岁时被从母亲身边带走，与一个老人在马车里生活，晚上在森林里的火边蜷缩，长达两年的脱衣服、游行、啜泣和凝视的考验。当这一切结束后，他的新家庭破碎了。他再次被遗弃。对他来说，从中走出来并在此后建立一个家庭，是一个胜利的故事。
I feel like my daddy could have had all the excuses in the world to be a drunk and a child abuser or anything, a rascal. He had a terrible, traumatic young life, but he chose my mother, and he chose to be a family man. And that was his world. That was his life. And I truly believe that those experiences, for him and for a mother who lost her father before she even knew him, were forces that gravitated them towards one another and towards a common feeling that they would be family.
我觉得我爸爸本来有无数借口可以成为一个酒鬼、一个虐待儿童的人或任何混蛋。他有一个糟糕而痛苦的童年，但他选择了我的母亲，选择了做一个顾家的男人。这就是他的世界。这就是他的一生。我真心相信，对于他和一位在认识父亲之前就失去了父亲的母亲来说，这些经历是促使他们相互靠近，并产生一种他们要成为一家人的共同感觉的力量。
I realize that I grew up in a charmed environment. Everybody can't say that. And Daddy couldn't say that, But he made that environment for us.
我意识到我在一个优越的环境中长大。不是每个人都能这么说。爸爸也不能这么说，但他为我们创造了那个环境。
At Swayze Lake, there are now houses where fishing shacks used to be. Margaret's standing on the concrete bridge that replaced the railroad trestle, looking out on the embankment where they found a four-year-old's footprints in 1912. After considering what Bobby Dunbar's disappearance did to everyone in three families for 100 years, there's only one person who's not accounted for. If Bobby was really Bruce, what happened to Bobby?
在斯韦兹湖，过去钓鱼棚的地方现在有了房子。玛格丽特站在取代了铁路栈桥的混凝土桥上，望着1912年他们发现四岁孩子脚印的堤岸。在考虑了鲍比·邓巴的失踪对三个家庭中所有人长达100年的影响后，只有一个人没有被交代清楚。如果鲍比真的是布鲁斯，那鲍比发生了什么？
I think he fell off this bridge and was eaten by an alligator and died. That's the most likely scenario.
我想他从这座桥上掉下去，被短吻鳄吃了，然后死了。这是最可能的情况。
When you think about the boy that died here, does that feel like your grandfather?
当你想到那个死在这里的孩子时，这感觉像是你祖父吗？
It's like my grandfather became two people. He was really Bruce Anderson. That's who he was born. That's where his blood came from, but he lived Bobby Dunbar's life.
就像我祖父变成了两个人。他其实是布鲁斯·安德森。那是他出生时的身份。那是他血缘的来源，但他却活了鲍比·邓巴的一生。
In 1932, when Bobby Dunbar was 24, he was asked to look back on his kidnapping. The Lindbergh baby had been stolen, and some reporters came around for a word with the famous kidnapped child of yesteryear.
1932年，鲍比·邓巴24岁时，被要求回顾他的绑架经历。林德伯格的孩子被偷了，一些记者过来想找这位昔日著名的被绑架儿童谈谈。
"A lot of people still believe I was eaten by an alligator," Bobby said in the interview. "I can assure you I was not." He went on to recount a memory of being with William Walters on the wagon on the road before the arrest, before he was recovered by the Dunbars. In the memory, there was another boy with him who fell off the wagon and died and was buried. There was a theory put forth by the prosecution at the trial that William Walters might have been traveling with two boys, Bobby Dunbar and Bruce Anderson. This would explain why two boys had been lost, but only one was found. It would answer the question, what happened to Bruce?
“很多人仍然相信我被短吻鳄吃了，”鲍比在采访中说。“我可以向你们保证我没有。”他接着回忆起被捕前，在鲍比被邓巴一家找回前，他在马车上和威廉·沃尔特斯在一起的记忆。在记忆中，还有另一个男孩和他在一起，他从马车上掉下来死了，并被埋葬了。在审判中，检方提出了一种理论，即威廉·沃尔特斯可能带着两个男孩旅行，鲍比·邓巴和布鲁斯·安德森。这就能解释为什么丢了两个男孩，却只找到了一个。它能回答这个问题，布鲁斯发生了什么？
19 years later, in 1932, Bobby had taken that theory and made it into a memory, a memory which might have served another purpose altogether. If Bobby Dunbar is to fully become Bobby Dunbar, then Bruce Anderson needs to be dead. Maybe it was by settling on this memory-- the other boy on the wagon-- that he created the legend he needed to begin his new life, his own legend of Bobby Dunbar.
19年后，在1932年，鲍比已经把那个理论变成了一种记忆，这种记忆可能有着完全不同的目的。如果鲍比·邓巴要完全成为鲍比·邓巴，那么布鲁斯·安德森就需要死。也许通过认定这个记忆——马车上的另一个男孩——他创造了他开始新生活所需要的传奇，他自己的鲍比·邓巴传奇。
Tal McThenia.
塔尔·麦克塞尼亚。
In the years since we first broadcast this story back in 2008, Jewel Tarver and Hollis Rawls have both died.
自从我们2008年首次播出这个故事以来的几年里，朱厄尔·塔弗和霍利斯·罗尔斯都已经去世。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg. Our senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Our technical director was Matt Tierney. Production help from Alvin Melathe.
我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格制作。本集的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。制作协助来自阿尔文·梅拉特。
Thanks today to Allen G. Breed, Francis and Earl Briggs, Wayne Cutright, Anna Lee Dunbar, David Dunbar, Imelda Dunbar, Chef Joe Durio, Ellen Luciano, Estelle Perrault, Martha Quillen, Ronnie Rawls and the Poplarville Public Library, Betty Redden, Margie Standard, Michael Walters, Tammy Westmoreland, Gerald Westmoreland, Frankie Bertrand, and Maureen Little of the Opelousas-St. Landry Chamber of Commerce.
感谢今天的艾伦·G·布里德、弗朗西斯和厄尔·布里格斯、韦恩·卡特赖特、安娜·李·邓巴、大卫·邓巴、伊梅尔达·邓巴、主厨乔·杜里奥、艾伦·卢西亚诺、埃斯特尔·佩罗、玛莎·奎伦、罗尼·罗尔斯和波普拉维尔公共图书馆、贝蒂·雷登、玛吉·标准、迈克尔·沃尔特斯、塔米·韦斯特莫兰德、杰拉尔德·韦斯特莫兰德、弗兰基·贝特朗以及奥佩卢萨斯-圣兰德里商会的莫琳·利特尔。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. We have lists of favorite shows. We have tons of other stuff there, too. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以完全免费在线收听我们750多集的档案。此外，还有视频。我们有最喜欢节目的列表。我们那里还有成堆的其他东西。再说一遍，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易中心发行。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says we young people have it so easy. He remembers what it was like back in the day to come the radio station every morning when he was a little boy.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他说我们年轻人太轻松了。他记得当年他还是个小男孩，每天早上来到广播电台时是什么样子的。
Through these woods, across an old hickory log, across a creek.
穿过这些树林，跨过一根古老的山核桃原木，穿过一条小溪。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "MYSTERY OF THE DUNBAR'S CHILD" BY RICHARD "RABBIT" BROWN]
[音乐 - 理查德·“兔子”·布朗演唱的《邓巴孩子的谜团》]